it's a warm lovely day and I'll try to
keep us all awake if I can and our
reward at the end of this at the end of
this lecture will be a reception to be
held outside so let's rock and roll our
topic tonight is sustainable stewardship
and if we could have the lights off it
will assist us all and sleeping more
soundly and i'll be taking pictures of
those who not off and posting it on the
internet I got but I before I actually
get into this talk though if you will
indulge me for five quick minutes I know
that there's folks here many of you that
are involved in graphics and in paper
conservation and photographic related
matters if I could just put that other
hat on for just a moment I wanted to
take just five minutes to familiarize
you with something that we are very
proud of at the image permanence
Institute that we have created as a
learning and teaching primarily teaching
tool for the identification and
understanding of graphics materials
images on paper starting back from
woodblock prints and going forward to
the latest digital materials and in
other words it's process ID it's a
teaching tool for process ID and it's to
be found on the web at graphics Atlas
one word org and this is graphics atlas
and i'll give you adjust the brief
astore of it everything on graphics
atlases arranged around processes you
see a pre photographic photomechanical
photographic and digital and within each
one for example within photographic
processes there are individual examples
and you can browse them by name if you
are
ready know that you want to you know
want to explore a chromolithograph you
can or there's a visual browser or you
can say does my thing look like this so
if your things amez attent i think yeah
okay with looks lure the mezzotint and
that takes you to one of the three ways
to look at each individual material this
is called the guided tour and the guided
tour has selected images that that tell
you about this particular graphic object
that you're looking at and things to
notice about it the prominent features
so you can click through them and each
lines the characteristic roc remarks and
markings of the mezzotint and so on you
can look at a little video of the
surface and when it works yeah there you
go all the materials there's a little
video back and forth mezzotint SAR matte
surface and have no reflections so if it
were glossy you would be able to see
that it's a bit analogous to holding in
your hand and there's a neat little
thing here we've clicked full screen all
of those things all of those views in
the guided tour you can click through
one by one and see it full screen so
that's the guided tour and you can also
do something called compare view where
you can compare one process to another
so if you wanted to compare a mezzotint
with oh I don't know let's see a
cyanotype what you see is there's this
there's a dimension bar that shows you
what every image on this and you'll see
that there are about twenty two images
of each process can be there made in
exactly the same way so in the compare
view there's a little there's a little
drivers console here where you can
control whether you're looking at the
front or the back you can change the
angle of light so if you want to raking
light to see the texture you
can do that you can do different
magnifications and you can also see
cross sections labeled with each one for
example here in the in the cyanotype you
see the ferrous ferric ferrocyanide
image in the paper fibers and there's
the ink on the mezzotint and so on and
there's a very neat full screen view for
the primary thing and there's to use the
arrow keys on your computer you can
cycle through you have to be on the
surface you can cycle through all the
magnifications and all the views and
change whether you're looking at it from
a 45 degree angle from a zero degree
angle or from a 90 degree angle so it's
a pretty it's an interesting virtual
print shop or a virtual lab where you
could study prints under the microscope
and really really begin to explore their
characteristics and the third view in
here is called identification so that's
a single page that takes you through hmm
this is not graphics atlases fault but
what we will do is start from home in
case it is graphics Alice's fall so if
you wanted to find out how to identify a
for example an inkjet print you can do
that here so there's a single page
telling you all about the key
characteristics of inkjet prints
different dot structures that they might
have different back printing there's
your little video of this particular
inkjet print and talking about abrasion
and so on so as if some of you may know
Bamber Gascoigne's book how to identify
prints this is a kind of electronic
version of that very thing and I think
it's very good for classroom teaching
and so on so thank you for indulging me
on that commercial graphics Atlas org
and now to the main event sustainable
stewardship
and the subtitle is really the important
one it's it's talking about the new
thinking on preservation environments
and building operations are there any
building operators in the audience any
bites if anybody wants to you know be
singled out for for building operations
sort of well everyone everyone has a
house so they're building operators for
that but anyway lets blend John this is
what Bobby told you about us at the
image permanence Institute and let me
take the opportunity to acknowledge the
sponsors neh IMLS Andrew W mellon
Foundation and the Society for imaging
science and technology they are the
people that have made IPI and all of its
work possible what I'm going to try to
do in the next little while is talk
about some of the ideas that have become
current in our work and the work of
others concepts talk about some of the
tools and approaches to managing
environments and focusing on a couple of
projects that we have been involved in
major ones at the Library of Congress
there's a project that we're embarking
on here at Yale University that is
funded by IMLS and in that project we
will be exploring the concept of saving
energy by shutting off air handlers
during during unoccupied hours in
library stacks basis and our sandbox for
this particular fun day at the beach
will be the stacks here in Sterling
library and which are served by six
different air handling units and we'll
be having fun with that and I will also
tell you about a similar experiment that
we have begun at the Library of Congress
and then I wanted to share with you the
opportunity to take a look at some new
museum storage buildings that are
extremely low energy that have been
built in Denmark
I could go on about them for a very long
time but we'll get to that every here's
a little part of this is going to be a
primer on on this whole subject I
recently had the opportunity to visit 10
historically black colleges and
universities and to consult with them on
the environments in their special
collections departments of their
libraries and this is the the library at
Prairie View A&M University in suburban
Houston Texas and it's a nice new
building that's that great collections
was built in the 1980s and this view has
a little symbolic thing going on because
one of the things that you need to know
about this whole subject is that the
outside climate is hugely determinative
of what the inside climate is like what
are the possibilities for saving energy
and the two things that combine to
create the inside climate are the
outside climate and the mechanical
systems inside the building just pause
to review some of the real fundamentals
here when you build a structure and have
systems to control the climate inside it
it's fairly easy to control temperature
they're machines to make cold and to
make heat are easy to build and easy to
control the tough job is controlling
moisture and that's what we want to do
in library and archive and museum
environments is we want control over
both temperature and moisture and it's
the moisture part part that's really the
difficult one and here is where the
complex complexity with the outdoor
climate comes into play we pay a lot of
attention and Environmental Management
to this parameter called dew point now
dewpoint is the temperature at which
monster will condense out of the air but
dew point is also a direct measure of
the amount of moisture in air and since
there's often too little moisture in the
outside air or two
much moisture in the outside air
depending on the season what you how
much outside air that comes into your
building and whether it's the right
quantity of moisture it has the right
dew point that's where that's where the
details get devilish and the more
outside air here's a little energy note
just in general you save energy by not
running machinery and when you're
bringing in more outside air and
especially when in the heart of the
summer of the are the heart of the
winter when it's it's it's too cold and
too dry or too warm and and too moist
that's when you spend a lot of money so
the more work you have to do on outside
air the less the worse it is for energy
well as far as the collection is
concerned and we're back again here at
Prairie View am in that building if you
go down to the basement of that building
that's where you see machines like this
that make the environment inside the
building this is what's called an air
handling unit and what you're looking at
is it's a big sheetmetal box is a fan in
the middle straddling each side in this
particular case is a these pipes behind
inside the machine is a cooling coil in
a heating coil and a fan those are the
real fundamental elements and it's this
machine's job to provide a human comfort
environment and to provide a suitable
environment for the collections and this
is a rare sight i'm going to show you
one of the rarest sites you've ever seen
there you see a meeting of the minds
between the library director and the
building operator together in the
mechanical rooms and you're going to
hear from me that the thesis of my work
is that the preservation of the
collection depends hugely on the storage
conditions I could talk till you are all
bleeding at the eardrums about the ways
in which temperature and mid attique
indicial e do affect
conditions but if you'll simply grant me
that if the jury will stipulate that we
can go on to talking about the other
stuff okay and so here you see here you
see what what ideally has to happen my
thesis will be that we can no longer if
we're in the preservation or were in the
collections part of of a cultural
institution we can no longer be an
effective advocate for the health of our
collections in this way unless we have a
kind of meeting of the minds and it was
really funny that the fellow there had
worked there for 11 years that that'd be
the guy in the blue shirt he is he's it
he is explaining a panel of controls
those missions the machine I just showed
you the air handler that is controlled
via computerized system and that's like
the little junction box where all the
all the wires that are connected to
individual valves and dampers go to sort
of a concentration point and from there
they are sent to a computer so this
fellow can operate this library systems
from his office which was across campus
or anyone in the whole Johnson Controls
organization could be thousands of miles
of what away can see what's going on and
operated this is what's called a BMS or
a building management system sometimes
called an energy management system the
funny part about getting everybody
together to see this I insisted that the
library directors and the archivists go
on a tour of the mechanical rooms and
this was that's what so rare about this
at one moment I said to the to the guy
here in the blue shirt I said wow I
guess this is the biggest biggest crowd
you've ever had down here and he said
this is the only crowd I've ever had
down and it was I i did this ten times
and sometimes they had to drag these
library directors kind of kicking and
screaming in through the mechanical
rooms but it's extremely instructive it
konkret izes what's going on
it embodies this idea embodies the whole
thing now one of the things you'll hear
me say in just a moment is how complex
these systems are and I explained that
there you know there was a computer
somewhere where you could see and
visualize the moving parts of this the
building management system this is what
one part of such a system would look
like this is the schematic part where
every moving part is represented and and
if you look closely there are little
values there this is what the operator
of a building sits at a computer
terminal and looks at screens like that
all right let's talk about
sustainability and really get get to the
fundamentals here environments cost a
lot of money they burn a lot of energy
in many cases that's fossil fuel energy
and as a rule of thumb you can think for
every square foot of temperature and
humidity-controlled space an average
cost per year just for the energy not
for the salary of the blue shirt guy not
for the amortized capital cost of
building it but just the amount of
electric and gas it burns each year is
four dollars per square foot on average
for example the University of California
Los Angeles has 850,000 square feet of
library stacks so you begin to do the
math and you're talking about big big
money I just showed you an example of a
building management system one of the
reasons why it's so rare that
preservation collections staff like
librarians and so on and facility staff
and building operators get together is
everybody's job is very very complicated
and from the building side the buildings
are really hard to understand they're
very individualistic there are many
generations of those building management
systems there's band-aids on top of
band-aids there are dumb systems
designed from the beginning there are
all kinds of reasons why understanding
them does not come you
and no one should underestimate the
reality that it's difficult now I asked
you to stipulate to me that environments
do matter for the collections and the
points that are important in a
sustainability context for that are
we've spent a long time I met more or
less at the tail end of my career but
I've spent at least 30 years studying
the ways in which materials deteriorate
in the laboratory causing them to
deteriorate through accelerated aging
reading about deterioration going to
conferences listening to people talk
about the ways in which collections are
harmed or helped by the environment and
what's the net result of all of that I
can say to you that most professionals
that are in the preservation field or in
the curatorial or librarian field would
would give less latitude for safe
environments for collections then I
think is real then I think the science
would support in other words there is
more latitude to do different things
with the environment that and I'll speak
to that point a little bit later but
here's a crucial point as well and that
is suppose we wanted to save some of
that big money some of the money we're
spending to condition to precise
temperature and humidity all those
square foot of libraries of museum
stores of archival materials how are we
going to do that what's going to be the
problem standing in the way is what's
going to be in the way is not the
ability to turn things off because
that's three clicks on the mouse you can
shut it off with three mouse clicks in
the password that's the easy part and
that will save you money the hard part
is knowing when to do that safely and
responsibly for your collections and
who's going to be prepared to answer
that is it going to be the facilities
person no is it going to be the CFO no
is it going to be the director or the
Dean or the chief curator whoever no
it's got to be the person
has the collections care
responsibilities be they conservator
preservation administrator or so on
their guidance is critical their input
is critical to achieving a sustainable
condition in these cultural institutions
in other words it ain't on those
buildings guys it ain't on the CFO it's
on the preservation and conservation
function and they have got to step up
and they are the ones who are going to
describe this envelope of reasonable op
safe operation for the collections it
might even be better big money while you
be the judge this is a woman that's an
archivist at at woodruff library in
Atlanta and they are to give you an idea
that she's standing in an air handler
she's standing in one of those machines
that make the environment she's standing
in front of a cooling coil that's 12
feet high in about 30 feet long and
there's another one it was same size
directly behind this one and so that
machine the cooling that runs through
that coil is provided by two machines
called chillers that are of this size so
when I say we're talking about big money
you don't want to pay the electric bill
you don't want to pay that the fuel
energy costs for these things okay so
here's here's where it comes down to the
scope of my interest in talk is it in
sustainability is not building the
greenest coolest new thing but working
with what we have and that's going to be
the case for quite a while the question
for large institutions is how do we work
with the buildings we have the
mechanical systems and collections that
we have in other words we want to
optimize them and to me this is where
sustainability is defined in practice
what is what is optimal operation well
environment is the best for the
collection it causes the least
deterioration it uses the least energy
least fuel natural
electricity and so on that it it's
workable for the people who have to use
the collections it's workable for the
workflows that the institution has to
actually fulfill its other functions the
baddest systems most sane sustainable
systems are also maintainable and simple
I cannot tell you how often things were
some designers bright idea and they're
turned off they're turned off people I
just I arrived here to find out that
there have been layoffs in the
facilities organization in this
institution recently and that's no one
they're not you're not alone in that at
all there's fewer and fewer people there
stretched thinner and thinner the
systems are more and more complicated
there is a huge premium on simplicity
and maintainability in all this and
finally in some institutions the
structure itself is part of the
collection that's true for many historic
homes and so on whatever the optimal
solution is to operate these massive
energy hog machines it has to be it has
to work with the structure can't ruin
the walls the building envelope and it
has to it has to be working in harmony
with the outdoor climate okay well
that's the principles optimal that's our
that's our mantra and our buzzword
optimal operation that was what we set
out to do at the library of congress
with a mellon Foundation grant in 1999
and now we're in our 11th year of
working with the preventive conservation
staff and the architect of the Capitol
staff at the Library of Congress and i'd
like to share with you a little bit of
what we're doing and what that has has
meant the lessons we've learned the way
we've worked at library of congress is
we work on two fronts the energy front
and the collections environment front at
once so we place um we place data
loggers this device here is called the
PE m2 that's a
a temperature and humidity recording
device it's about this big and it's
battery-powered very portable and you
can retrieve the data from it by putting
a USB flash drive into a little port on
the side and it will it will write a
text file on that USB flash drive that
tells you the temperature humidity
conditions and so they have
approximately 150 such devices scattered
in the in the three principal buildings
of the library of congress and and they
tell us what the collections are
experiencing at the same time we're
measuring inside selected air handling
units those machines that make the
climate and there you see June wheeler
by the way I was a partner in an energy
consulting firm that we have worked with
called hertzog wheeler and associates
june by the way 1981 yale alumna in
architecture yay local girl makes good
and that is jeremy linden of the ipi
staff I'm sorry messing it up here and
they are they're standing outside a
large but by no means the largest ever
air handler that serves exactly half of
the Adams building the Adams building is
the 1934 building on capitol hill it has
12 stack levels I don't know how many
million volumes of books in one in one
giant block square building and there
are two air handlers that serve all
those books tax and north union and
south unit and so we are measuring the
amount of energy that is consumed by the
north and part by the South stack air
handler and what we've been doing is
recently is turning it off at eight
o'clock at night and turning it on at
six o'clock in the morning shut off dead
end of story there are no staff in there
at that time and there is there is no
reason to have ventilation so
just by dint of this we have estimated
that if we did that year round if we
turned it off every night and turned it
on again every morning year round it
would save in the in this unit alone
80,000 US dollars in fuel energy so
between the two units if we did it in
both sides it would be a hundred sixty
thousand dollars per year just by
turning it off at night so when I say
it's big money and big savings that are
possible it really is but you have to do
it safely the trick is what happens when
you turn it off and in the real world
sometimes very little happens happily so
far that's been the case in the Adams
South stacks you can see a tiny little
blip but we have the ability in the
technology to know what that means to
the collection and it don't mean much so
as long as the collections cruising
along happily why not put that eighty
thousand bucks in your pocket each year
and just think there are two other
buildings there in the library of
congress one of them called the james
madison building is the newest one it
has 42 air handlers in the penthouse and
another 16 air handlers in the basement
you get the idea I mean I'm not trying
to oversell this but there's real money
involved and it's it's really worth
thinking about well how do you address
that critical question of when is the
collection as the result of anything as
a result of the phases of the moons of
Jupiter or you turn in things off or
just the way they did it or just the way
they've always done it the problem is
one of prima facie understanding what
the collections are experiencing and
what that might mean in terms of
deterioration and this is a this is a
give you an idea of how that judgment
call has been made not only here in
sterling but in many institutions
hundreds of different institutions are
are using our environmental assessment
methods which begin by collecting
temperature and humidity data
continuously and by the way you ain't
got no data you just punk you know
what's that what's that what's that
saying you know money talks and
something else walks you know data talks
and everything else walks if you don't
have data if you don't know what your
collections are experiencing you're just
kind of out out of luck because you
can't get the first base I know there's
a lot of Red Sox fans here right you
understand that analogy without
temperature humidity data you don't get
the first base all right so when you
have temperature and humidity data a lot
of people think that they're able to
then understand what the collections are
experiencing yeah right that's what we
spent 25 years of research to try to
figure out is that surely there are ways
to take that basic information about
temperature and moisture and then derive
something that's more meaningful to us
that that helps us understand whether
it's good or bad or precisely how good
or bad it is for collections so here's
the kind of console view that you might
see these are the different spaces here
are forms of deterioration that can
affect cultural heritage objects natural
aging is slow chemical changes that's a
big one for libraries mechanical damage
that's due to the swelling and shrinking
that's very important for objects made
of wood or objects like paintings or
ivory or bone or lacquered objects
things of that kind where the the
relative humidity of the air determines
the moisture content of the object and
through a dry winter or a damp summer
the object will expand and contract how
much it expands how much it contracts
and how big that excursion is between
its its extremes of expansion and
contraction those are parameters which
you can use to
manage the environment and so then
there's mold growth mold will not grow
under many common environmental
conditions we all know that damp
conditions promote mold growth so and
then finally there's metal corrosion
which again requires a certain amount of
moisture well the sort of console view
to tell you what the collections are
experiencing one part of it can be
boiled down to idiot lights like this
red bad green good you know and okay
okay so you can see it you know you're
just like okay there it is but you know
and it's also dependent on what period
of time that you're looking at if you
want a little bit more nuanced
understanding of how good or bad the
environment is with respect to these
things that are critical to collections
care then you look at these numbers
which we call the preservation metrics
and these numbers are derived from the
raw temperature and humidity data and
each one of them I'm not going to
explain them in detail but that's the
one that relates to chemical aging it's
very important for fading of dyes and
degradation of paper that's a factor
that tells you whether mold would be
possible and when it's in red it says
pay attention to me these particular
spaces are all problematic from the
natural aging point of view one of them
is beginning to be problematic from the
mold point of view and several of them
are problematic because they get too
damn well I show you this only that to
explain that there are ways now to use
quantitative quality control metrics to
control preservation environments and
when they when they're in use they work
and we've been using those for a long
time now if you wanna here's the really
important lesson that we've learned it
at LC environment you know the people
who nobody raises their hand to say they
were a building's facilities type person
right if you're there you're probably
going like this now
let me say something sort of pejorative
and stereotypical about that role it's
not really pejorative it's real life if
you or I were in that role we'd to be
doing the same thing which is that when
you think about environment they think
about environment as a project
environment is yeah well we'll get the
equipment to do the job they don't think
about it the way we think I think you
should approach it which is as a process
really facilities people it's either a
project that has to be designed and
built and scoped and budgeted or it's a
trouble call or a comfort complaint
that's all there is there is no like
look at it every day see how it's doing
or look at it every month you know it's
a project or it's a trouble call or it's
a human comfort complaint and and humans
can use the telephone and they can call
up and say i'm too hot i'm too cold and
that will drive the actions that's one
key feedback mechanism for the building
operators but the collections they lost
the number i mean it was so
heartbreaking they lost that building
guy's number you know they had it
written down on a post it note and they
stuck it somewhere and now i fell off
and now they can you know the books
can't call anybody anymore so that's
that's you know if you're going to
address and change that circumstance it
has to you have to go after it it's a
process it's people getting together and
talk it's not a numerical specification
by the way managing and environment is
not is not calling up your buddy at the
other conservation lab and saying well
what do you do well we do 70 50 ok
that's what I'm going to tell the
architect we want that isn't managing
your environment it's not a numerical
specification in fact no single
environment is best for every kind of
object so it can't be approached that
way and really the way to think about
environmental management for
preservation and sustainability is
by analogy to modern manufacturing think
about the way that automobiles our
manufactured and famously even though
Toyota's have it a lot of problems
lately people in did you know did you
read that in the paper people still buy
Toyota's okay they're not they're not
hurt and Akio Toyoda is not about to
commit seppuku because this gas pedal
stuck a little bit they still sell them
and people still buy and why because
they're really well made and the
manufacturing prowess of Japan is well
known and they invented these concepts
of continuous improvement in many cases
and if you're a modern manufacturing
modern manufacturing is done on these
ideas that that it's never finished it's
a process of continuous examination of
the production line of the costs that go
into producing the product it's a
constant reassessment of quality control
and if we can make that analogy the
environment is something that's
manufactured every day down there those
machines those aah use they're not
stamping out widgets they're stamping
out temperature and humidity conditions
and if we don't pay attention to how
they're working we're not going to ever
get any better so what's preservations
role in this modern manufacturing
process we can make that analogy the
preservation role is as designer because
after all it's not the facilities it's
not the library director it's it's the
preservation and conservation role to
say what the environment should be to
lay out its key points and then it's up
to other people to manufacture it but
then they have another key role which is
quality control which is what I just
showed you we're using the metrics and
you know what metrics are found in every
area of manufacturing and you can
improve automobile production lines
unless you have some way of measuring
defects and reducing them and so you're
part of a production team if you're in
the preservation world and that
production team is making the
environment whose goal is optimal
operation remember all those things
working together in harmony
you know who it just gives me goose
bumps to think about it but the
participants in this process are the
collection care professionals the
building operators themselves the people
who love and owned the collection the
curators librarians archivists and the
staff and then the administrators who
oversee the whole thing including the
money people and they all together share
the responsibilities for stewardship of
the collections for cost control because
people are getting laid off because
these systems are chewing up too much
money and for sustainability in the
sense of being a responsible global
citizen I mean it should bother everyone
that it unnecessary energy waste it is
harming the planet and it is spending
money that could be used for much better
things I had to throw this in you know I
i I'm a former English major and I love
that analogy of manufacturing you know
continuous improvement and today I got
this email I had to throw it in here at
RIT where I work you know there was an
email advertising are it's-- Lean Six
Sigma yellow belt certification program
now have you all had that conversation
with somebody and you're saying well
what do you do and they say I'm a six
sigma black belt never had the
conversation huh let me break this down
for you okay what you know what lean is
you know lean is like in manufactures
manufacturing jargon and this is where
manufacturing is if you want it you know
we're a school that teaches real place
manufacturing as much as we got left in
this country you know on lean
manufacturing means you're you don't
have any unnecessary parts inventory and
all of that six sigma everybody in tune
with six sigma how many Sigma's you got
here do you seriously do everybody not
know what six Sigma's how many people
not know what six sigma is ok if you
are hopelessly out of touch yeah when
you do a real quality control and you
have those measurements of quality like
you're making widgets Six Sigma means
Sigma is the is the is a measure of the
number of wrongly manufactured parts for
the sake of thinking about it and six
sigma is 0 point 0 0 0 0 1 percent of
parts are made in a defective manner so
if your six sigma like if you work for
motorola making cell phones motorola is
obsessed with six sigma there are people
whose whose careers are six sigma and so
many so that they had to have like six
sigma nu be you know white white you
know and it's like the dojo where you're
learning karate first you get the robe
and you feel all self-conscious and you
know and then you get you know what's
the first belt you get white belt or
something and then you progress up
through brown belt yellow bell and if
you're black belt and then you know so
like this this program here that they're
advertising and emails in my campus is
like yeah you can sign up for this
three-day course to learn how to do
quality control so that you are at point
0 0 0 0 1 defects okay so that
manufacturing today does embody if you
read through the text at the bottom it
does embody complicated things done
cooperatively and my thesis here in this
talk is that that's the way I see
institutional preservation and
sustainability programs working together
to understand that it's a process to
understand people's responsibilities and
people hold up their end of the deal
it's absolutely hopeless by the way to
expect that facilities people would
understand collections care and
preservation and and but they need to
know enough about it that they can
function as part of the team and
therefore we as well this is chip and
Kevin
this is part of the Library of Congress
project too I mean when we first started
there in 1999 we did not have wondrous
cooperation from the building operators
but now we do and it's really proof that
I mean now we work there and these guys
take care of the items building and they
are the front lines of sustainability in
the library of congress in this respect
that if anybody is going to save the
eighty thousand dollars it's going to be
chipping kevin and they have to
understand what's going on and and they
do and it's a real pleasure to work with
them so i know the process can work and
the man in the right on the black is
there that's Peter her talk he's the
energy specialist on our team and the
person on the left is work set IP I
Jeremy he'll be working here in in
sterling they are standing in that air
handler that serves adam south and that
gives you some idea that that is a large
machine and indeed it is and that is Ben
ballman he's the preservation liaison
for the project and he's pointing to one
of our daily data loggers that is
helping us to understand when the system
goes on and goes off so I I wanted to
emphasize that the preservation role in
this you don't have to know what these
you don't have to know the building so
well you can fix everything you don't
have to know the energy-saving part so
well that you can puzzle out the BTUs
but you have to know enough to be a team
player and you do have to take
possession of gathering data and using
these metrics and you do have to know
enough about your collection to know
what its particular needs are and and
you can't just read it in a book and and
so on that's the datalogger I was
talking about now I'm going to beat up
for a while on the on the need to to
have a close idea of quality control
most people who collect temperature
metadata just see the graph like this
which is impossible to understand
Annalise yes if you've been doing it for
15 years you get some idea but it's a
far cry from what I just showed you and
a lot of people's idea about the
environment and this comes from the
museum world is that the ideal
environment for collections is very
steady it's about 70 degrees Fahrenheit
comfortable for humans and and then
doesn't very very much and fifty percent
rh kind of the middle of the humidity
range and it doesn't vary more than say
five percent up or down that you might
say is the current museum standard next
Monday and Tuesday is it is a meeting a
very high-level summit meeting at the
Museum of Fine Arts in Boston by museum
conservators and others i'll i'll be
attending i'll probably have to wear a
helmet but i will be attending the whole
idea is that even for the real high-end
art museums this this hand-me-down
standard is not is under attack it's not
workable it is good for one thing 70
degrees fifty percent RH is not the
ideal environment for your collection it
has however one absolutely useful
feature if you're going to be exhibiting
stuff it's convenient for the visitors
who come to the exhibit if you're going
to be putting different types of objects
together the fifty percent rh level is
probably the best compromise for showing
different kinds of objects but that's as
far as its beauty and wonderment go
because as the next dot says it's mad
money for most climates it really is
very expensive it's kind of the enemy of
sustainability because if that's the way
if that's your position you want it
steadily 70 degrees and fifty percent rh
your kind of locked out of the
sustainability game and you're paying
mad money for that mad money and the
street sentence of that's a lot of money
and mad money and the other sense of mad
like you're mad if you do that because
um you know but anything like I say it's
incompatible sustainable operations and
here in a library 7050 is really bad for
library collections because it's too
warm you're cooking the books I talked
about the metrics they really allow you
to do that and I wanted to point out
another website that's very instructive
called DP calc org and this is a website
that we created where you can explore
the interrelationship between
temperature humidity and dew point and
you can see on the right hand side those
idiot lights and the values of those
metrics and you can see how there is no
one perfect environment there's a
continuum and some environments are
better for preserving objects that might
degrade through spontaneous chemical
change like paper and textiles some
environments are better for for other
kinds of materials or assemblages of
materials and you can explore that here
and it's a very good teaching tool Tara
was saying to me to our Kennedy the
preservation field services officer here
and Sterling was saying to me just today
this is if you know if you don't know
this you don't know nothing because this
is the fundamental relationships that
guide the whole thing whether you're
trying to make the environment or you're
trying to understand it anyway the
bottom line in our 11 years at LC and
there you see Nancy level examiner who's
the the preventive conservation
supervisor at the library together with
Peter hertzog and Ben who works for
Nancy and and they the lesson we've
learned is remember going back to that
optimal operation if you think that your
place might be by chance optimal already
forget about it does forget about it
that's one thing we've seen over and
over again is that you can safely assume
it's not optimal unless you've really
looked at it and and tried to make it
that the last thing I wanted to share
with you was a new idea
that is particular really I think to
museum objects and particular to certain
climates but it's very interesting from
the low energy point of view the Danes
when the Arab oil embargo hit in the
1970s there were the Danes had a
reaction like oh we got to save energy
from now on and they've been added ever
since in a very very serious way our
reaction was oh gee there's a long line
at the gas station I can't wait till
that's over oh it's over okay and we
went on happily ignoring the whole darn
thing and you know it's interesting to
see what you could do if you didn't do
that and at the National Museum of
Denmark they have a group of scientists
and engineers that that work exclusively
with the idea of designing buildings
from the ground up that our storage for
archives and museum objects and they
used very very little energy and I
wanted to show you two of them one of
them is in the town of viola in Denmark
it's a museum storage building that is a
cooperative among seven museums and then
it's it's son or daughter or whatever
you want to call it another building
from another museum in another town that
was designed along the same principles
so hey you know you're not in Kansas
when you see a building like this right
this is the viola um cooperative
storehouse it doesn't look like much
it's not winning any awards for
landscaping I don't think either it's
not exactly the architectural triumphs
of the of Europe but that's what it
looks like on the outside the really
cool part and this is what it looks like
on the inside it's 600 square metres of
about 30 feet high ceilings it's a
one-story building it needs to be to be
the kind of very low energy building
that it is i'll explain that in a second
but that gives you a feeling for the
kind of objects that are there the
violet environment is
completely the environment inside it is
a prize winner on our metrics and by any
estimation it is a real it's a champ RH
is steady at about fifty five percent
all year long the temperature varies
this is a basic design the RH is steady
and the temperature varies and the
temperature goes from about 45 degrees
inside in winter to about 65 degrees in
summer and there's there are never any
violent spikes in relative humidity
because the interior walls which are
made of a special concrete and the
collections themselves to some degree
buffer the relative humidity here are
some of the secrets to making this
building do its magic it has no outside
air there's no intentionally introduced
outside air from leakage the doors
opening and so on they have measured it
to be about one and a half air changes
per day so the inside air is replaced by
outside air only one and a half times a
day does that sound like a lot to you a
building like this probably undergoes 17
to 20 air changes per day the room we're
in so that's very low and as far as
quality goes the TWP is over 100 here in
sterling most of the TWP is are about 50
55 there's very little dimensional
change because the RH hardly varies it
all throughout the year there's no mold
because fifty-five percent rh won't
stand on support mold and here's the
here's the punch line here's the money
shot total energy costs three dollars
per kilowatt hour three dollars kill ok
i'm screwing up my money line to operate
the building it costs three dollars per
cubic meter per year and that I i I'm
mislabeled the slide but it's three
dollars per cubic meter now it's a floor
area 600 square metres and it's 30 feet
high so
you get the idea but that is peanuts it
is peanuts and another concern went okay
if you put all your museum objects in a
closed box like this how come it it
doesn't it foul its own nest doesn't the
collection objects produce pollutants
and by careful selection you'll notice
it has certain it's basically all metal
except for the collections all metal and
concrete all the finishes are selected
so they don't out gas so it doesn't foul
its own nest with pollutants and they've
actually made these measurements this is
a slide that came from those guys and
here's the mechanical room for this very
large building it has a tiny little
desiccant dehumidifier this thing there
is an air handler it's a little bit
different scale air handlers of ones
I've been showing you and it has it has
no cooling the building has no cooling
there is no way to cool the building the
building is cool because it sits on the
ground and in the winter they the
concrete floor adds a little heat and in
the summer the concrete floor acts as a
sink for he actually cools the building
now part of the secret of this building
is it it works in the Danish climate
which is cool and damp and somewhat
cloudy I think the Cullens from Twilight
you know after they left Forks the
Cullens moved here to Copenhagen you got
to watch you got to go to movies and
read teenage novels to get that joke but
anyway it's cold and it's damp but it
doesn't get real cold and it doesn't get
real hot either and that's you know
that's a similar climate too much of the
northwest of the United States by the
way and so this air handler merely stirs
the air around there's a fan with a tiny
motor there is a heating coil in there
but it doesn't go on hardly at all and
in fact the heat generated by the air
dryer is enough to both heat and
dehumidified the building and the lights
are off most of the time there's no one
in there most of the time
and like I said it just sips energy and
here's a building that was built along
the same lines with slightly different
materials in an town called Reba and
this give you an idea that's the
relative humidity here the humidifier
failed but it's flat fifty-five percent
all the time and this is just when the
dehumidifier is on here's the
temperature floating with the seasons
cooler in the winter slightly warmer but
never hot in the summer remember they
got a climate that doesn't get too hot
in the summer and too cold in the winter
but there are ideas about this that
could be adapted to made many places in
the US and this is the energy used by
the dehumidifier so a very very
interesting building and here's here's
from their own scientists these are the
keys to building a building like that
they say low winter temperatures it
benefit but it doesn't get low by our
standards and that's that's good because
they would have to begin to add moisture
if it did the humidification they find
is cheaper than humidistat akita ng and
the low ventilation rates the fact that
the building is fairly tight keeps the
outdoor pollutants out and yet inside is
not fouled by collection generated
pollutants although you do have to pay
attention to what you make the building
out of and here's the key the slab the
concrete floor is doing all the work of
heating and cooling it and they've
discovered that it's important that the
floor not be insulated but the walls the
side walls and roof be insulated very
well thermally so when we come back and
look at our own buildings i think
there's there's lots of lessons and lots
of opportunity for sustainability
improvements and if you want a last
thing i want to show you is this little
things to look at to save energy in a
building like we have in like most of
our libraries and museums keys are you
you're not going to save money unless
you understand how the systems work
typically there are low-hanging fruit up
tunities the things that consume energy
are cooling the air and heating it back
up when you don't have to in order to do
middle I when you don't have to running
your fans too much letting in too much
outside air and use the preservation
metrics to really regulate the whole
thing so thank you very much for coming
I hope I didn't go too long I did go too
long I'm sorry so if you want to if you
if you absolutely love this if this was
riveting to you I mean I know you're on
the edge of your seat like what can I do
now then you can go to our website image
permanence institute org and sign up for
our exciting climate notes newsletter
which is a quarterly newsletter
e-newsletter that discusses a lot of
these topics in detail so thank you very
much